par contre au chapitre des exploits de
cette transat française il y à la
performance de florence arthaud elle a
été la première femme à l'arrivée vous
le savez et surtout elle s'est classée
11e c'est à dire une très bonne place
vous l'avez entendu déjà brièvement ce
soir je vous propose d'écouter le récit
qu'elle a fait à pierre salviac de sa
course
florence arthaud j'ai souffert mais
jamais aux palangres était jamais parce
que vous ma retraite est à 100 ça sert à
rien j'aurais jamais regretté
j'ai soufflé des moments j'ai vraiment
eu envie de lever le pied de
laisser-aller d'aller dormir
je me dis à chaque fois bon bah tu
t'égares tu gardes ton chemin il faut
vous foncez tant pis découvert aux
consignes et renvoie de la loi ceci cela
et puis je repartais se dirait jamais
longtemps hein mais il y avait toujours
souvent quand il ya des trucs qui allait
pas qu'ils cassaient causé maximum et
quelques à côtés on voyait que ça
marchait pas on a toujours des moments
où on en a mais vraiment mais ras le bol
ras le bol mois la fin est comme ça à
l'époque j'étais sur mon cou il j'ai
gueulé l'injurier enfin je crois c'était
et puis bon après je ne reprenais
j'agisse et ont passé à l'action
continue on continue à se dire que en
fait l'ambiance dans cette course était
il fallait penser à rien d'autre
rien d'autre que la course que font ses
skis et on a des ornières
on n'habite à plein c'est allé vite
toujours été possible mais ni son bateau
au maximum quelles que soient nos états
d'âme quel que soit notre fatigue notre
santé par là la forme physique est bien
ce qu il faut penser qu'à ça surtout pas
se dire
enfin je sais pas on n'a pas le loisir
le loisir d'avoir de s'occuper à autre
chose et on n'a pas le loisir non plus
de penser à autre chose
florence vous portez sur vos mains les
meurtrissures de la cour alors quels ont
été les moments les plus pénibles à
c'était moi je crois que les mômes en
fête les plus pénibles je sais pas
vraiment celle ci c'est au moment où ça
casse et parce que le moral de son nez
complètement parce que quand quand vous
défoncer depuis le départ vous dormez
pas qu'on fait le maximum que vous êtes
crevé et que finalement vous vous faites
le maximum mais que c'est le matériel
qui lâche c'est en dessous que ça a
vraiment un jusqu'en juillet mais c'est
dégueulasse et page et c'est ce que je
sais c'est pas normal
ça doit arriver et on est arrêté on perd
du temps exécrable parce que c'est parce
que c'est les choses sur le bateau qui
casse alors que nous on fait le maximum